Sir. Looking for Captain Leo.
You must've really messed up
if they sent you to Leo.
Do you know why you're here?
Because I broke chain of command.
Harp, he's not like us.
-You're a--
-Your commanding officer,
and I'm giving you
60 seconds to deal with it.
Yes, sir.
Cool.
What are you? AI?
A Gump's AI. I'm a prototype.
My existence is classified.
But I can't do this alone.
I need someone who can
think outside the box.
That's why you're here.
I chose you.
-You got a picture of her?
-I'm not having this conversation.
Hey, it's fair game, rookie.
She's a hottie. Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Hey.
"My gummy bear?"
My gummy bear.
Please, tell me what you know.
-In front of him?
-You can trust him.
These are your informants.
Listen, I'm a combat soldier,
but I feel more than you think.
I can't do this with eyes on me.
They put your tracker
on your back?
Sometimes you gotta get dirty
to see any real change.
Welcome to the war, kid.
This seems a bit beyond protocol
for whatever you are.
I need you to trust me, Harp.
What will you do
with so much power?
We can be good allies.
In extreme situations,
I have the ability
to break the rules just like you.
What's going on, Harp?
-I removed his fail-safe.
-You did what?
If your war machine
turns against you,
why should I care?
How long do you think
you'll survive out here?
on your own
What are you using me for?
Do you trust me?